the presidents Justice Department is
coming under new scrutiny scrutiny over
its surveillance of the Trump campaign
chief intelligence correspondent
Catherine Herridge tells us about a big
announcement today on the fights at
court
good evening Cathy well thank you bread
the Justice Department's internal
watchdog knee-deep in the investigation
of the handling of the Clinton email
case will now take on alleged
surveillance abuse during the 2016
election yes it will be investigated
taking questions at a Justice Department
news commerce on the opioid crisis the
Attorney General was pressed on the
House Intelligence Committee memos and
whether laws were broken when a
surveillance warrant was created for
Trump campaign aide Carter page will
your department investigate and if the
evidence is there hold FBI and Justice
Department officials in contempt we
believe the Department of Justice must
adhere to the high standards in the FISA
Court I think that's just the
appropriate thing the Inspector General
well I take that as one of the matters
he'll deal with after rescheduling White
House communications director hope Hicks
finally testified behind closed doors
the White House news they decide what
they go to do an executive privilege
sense of a thing
our Republican source said Hicks
answered questions about the campaign
but not about her time in the White
House it's not clear whether she invoked
executive privilege I'm not gonna
comment on any individuals interactions
with the committee but we are
cooperating because as the president has
said repeatedly there is no collusion
also on Capitol Hill the director of the
National Security Agency was pressed by
Senate Democrats on the administration's
commitment to thwarting Russia's past
and future election interference you
said that President Trump has never
ordered Cybercom
to take any action to defend or thwart
Russian attempts to meddle in the
elections this fall is that correct I've
never given given any specific direction
to take additional steps outside my
authority and I have taken the steps
within my authority you know trying to
be a good proactive commander Rogers
said punishing the Russians could take
many forms from diplomacy to economic
sanctions and offensive cyber
capabilities there are tools available
to us and again I think in fairness you
can't say nothing's been done but my
point would be it hasn't been enough but
the White House disagreed we are taking
a number of steps to prevent this and
we're looking at a variety of other ways
that we're going to continue to
implement over the coming weeks and
months in a separate development the
special council has moved to dismiss the
bank and tax fraud charges in Virginia
against former Trump campaign associate
Rick Gates the filing is tied to gates
agreement Friday to plead guilty to
conspiracy to defraud the United States
and lying to the FBI Brett Catherine
thank you